what did you learn about uh confidence
for guys around girls like if there was
someone that you were speaking to that
was a friend or whatever that was like
I'm just really super unconfident with
girls is there any interesting reframes
or insights that you relied on when you
were starting to build your confidence
where you think like that actually
helped like that was a really good
useful framing for me to think about
interacting with women
ah like for me it was more about
I was not happy with where I was at in
my life with the with my dating life and
lack of it entirely essentially so
typically guys who are underachieving in
some area if you I guess are wired a
certain way you may feel overly
motivated to compensate for that in some
way which could lead to you
almost overachieving that area to feel
like you've reached the Baseline that
somebody else who has just had it from I
don't know like a normal transition into
high school or whatever and had it you
know silver platter to them or something
because some guys they're just you know
we'll just get girls you know naturally
or they're naturally charismatic and
they don't have to like develop
whatsoever just turning off this alarm
for the Rogan comment
um
but yeah so for me it was more so like
can I foresee this as my life in the
future and am I satisfied with it and at
the time it was not something that I was
happy with and not something I felt like
oh in 10 years is this something that is
sustainable and that I feel
is something that I could ever be happy
with no it wasn't so I have to make a
change because this is just unacceptable
for me and at that point
I was just pushing myself massively out
of my comfort zone like it was not a
what did that look like like literally
going around my campus in between
classes and just you know talking to
girls that I thought were attractive and
just striking up conversations
essentially
and the reason for that is to overcome
approach anxiety fear yeah yeah so it
was uh and this was like before Tinder
and stuff really took off so there was a
very very like it was necessary to
actually talk to people in real life
still and maybe that's you know that has
shifted a little bit in recent times and
maybe it's more important to have like a
high level social media following and
you know Leverage The the DMS game and
stuff but
um I do think it's very important and
impactful on communication skills your
ability to articulate yourself the
ability to have high level even like
business presentations job interviews to
be able to if you can go up to a some
woman who you find attractive that's
sitting there that you've never met
before and just strike up a conversation
have like a reasonable dialogue you know
get her number go on a date like you
could pretty much crush anything that
has to do with you know talking to a bro
or to a you know a potential employer
like oftentimes I find guys are most
scared of somebody they find that
they're trying to get something from
maybe or they otherwise are afraid of
rejection like admirable yeah I think
it's hard to it's hard to put into words
but if you can
oftentimes if you walk up to somebody
you deem to be extremely attractive and
you otherwise were terrified to talk to
you and that becomes like a a nothing
thing where you have no anxiety about it
and you can just smoothly on a whim walk
up to a girl and have a conversation and
introduce yourself and have a reasonable
dialogue
you can very much
throw yourself into a lot of social
situations that otherwise seemed
overwhelming prior how did you get over
the approach anxiety Beyond just it
being reps and this goes for girls as
well like girls also kind of need to get
over their own approach anxiety in a
post-metu world all of the dating advice
that they used to get which was why men
love [ __ ] and treat him like you
don't like him if girls roll forward
with that same like you know aloof Style
guys are going to take no as [ __ ] no not
uh maybe I need you to try a little bit
harder and be a bit more flirty with me
or something like that's the old world
and you know post 2010s they don't get
to do that anymore
was there anything that you relied on
like you're looking at the person that
you're going to go and speak to and
there's a ringing in your ears and your
heart rate's at 120 and you're like
sweating what got you over the hill of
being able to begin doing that
um for me it was seeing people that I
found to be relatable
able to get over it themselves so I was
inspired by certain people that I saw
who had weren't happy with their lives
also be able to get over that and become
socially fluent have no anxiety walk up
on a whim to anybody they please Etc and
strike up what I feel to be high enough
level conversations that a woman is even
impressed or coming up to her
depending on the scenario because it
depends on you know if you're good
looking you're not creepy if you're not
good looking then you aren't like
there's a whole [ __ ] debate about
that whole thing where at the end of the
day all you can do is maximize yourself
value through all of these different
vectors of gym lifestyle Etc But
ultimately these social components is
very controllable and something you can
develop and yeah it sort of is a reps on
reps thing unfortunately to some extent
and I think just jumping into the fire
or you know whatever saying you wanna
you know taking the plunge whatever it
often is just the necessary thing that
needs to be done to be able to develop
socially and I don't know if you need
somebody to hold your hand to do it I
don't necessarily know that
you you might be just giving yourself an
excuse like at the end of the day you're
not happy with your life so are you
going to change it or you're not like
you have to take some [ __ ] action at
the end of the day so for me it was very
motivating I saw a couple guys that were
capable of doing it and I suppose that
gave me a bit more inspiration than
maybe I would have otherwise had from
Baseline but at the end of the day I
didn't have somebody walk up with me to
the first girl I talked to I still had
to go up to her and say hi my name is
Derek what's yours I thought you were
cute I want to come talk to you Etc
whatever it was like once you get your
foot in the door and say something that
shows your intent very clearly you
introduce yourself you then put out the
premise that you know I'm interested in
you are you open to you know a
conversation or not and you've either
succeed or you don't and oftentimes you
won't but you'll never be able to figure
out if it was a successful thing or not
if you don't just try and talk to people
and that even goes to talking to dudes
like if you want to make a friend or
whatever or talk to a guy at the gym ask
for a spot like whatever it is like you
have to have some balls to be able to
talk to humans outside of in a online
you know
gaming context or whatever I wonder
whether in the same way as porn has
given people a get out of jail free card
for uh faked signals of fitness and like
reproductive satisfaction if online
dating has done the same thing for
people not needing to develop
yeah like at the end of the day with
online dating you still have to meet up
with the girl and talk to her so you
could argue that it's just a more time
efficient way to do it and I'm not I'm
not debating that I think it is highly
useful the problem is with online dating
is you very much can't convey your
humor as well often or your tonality or
certain things that might otherwise set
you apart in person so I'm not saying
that you shouldn't rely on just online
dating because a lot of guys will just
crush it if they're have good enough
pictures and they have a good enough
profile but mostly pictures like they'll
crush it but a lot of guys won't like I
don't know if you've seen the statistics
on Tinder success rates of men versus
women it's like I don't know what it is
now it's probably like five percent of
men get 90 to 95 of the girls or
something and it's like well then what
do you do are you just [ __ ] do you
just do nothing like obviously you need
to if you want some level of I don't
know like a high quality relationship in
your life you have to take some action
some capacity and I don't think the
excuses well it's just not gonna happen
because Tinder didn't work out like
figure it out what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]